mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question à laquelle
j'associe mes collègues dromois
Marie-Pierre Monier et Gilbert boucher
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
alors que notre assemblée vient de lui
rendre hommage une marche blanche se
déroule actuellement dans la Drome à
roman suriser en souvenir de Thomas âgé
de 16 ans mortellement poignardé à
crépul dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche
nos pensées vont à sa famille ses amis
son lycée ses camarades de club de rugby
à toutes les personnes blessées ainsi
qu'à l'ensemble des habitants de ce
village meurtris par cette tragédie
samedi soir alors que le traditionnel
bal d'hiver était organisé par le comité
des fêtes de cette commune de 500
habitants la convivialité a été stoppée
par l'atrocité selon le procureur de la
République au cours de ces violences
plus d'une quinzaine de personnes ont
été blessées madame la Première ministre
face à une telle violence gratuite et
débridée nous partageons la sidération
et la peine des habitants de notre
département pour nous androme c'est tout
sauf un fait d'hiver
l'émotion nous tenaille à cette douleur
s'ajoutent d'inévitables questions
pourquoi pourquoi eux pourquoi à crépole
pourquoi Thomas une enquête est en cours
et elle devrait je l'espère apporter des
réponses je salue la réactivité des
forces de l'ordre qui ont procédé hier à
l'interpellation de neuf individus pas
de conclusions hative laissons la
justice travailler cela étant vu la
nature de ces actes criminels qui
semblent prémédités et réalisés en bande
organisé nous devons collectivement nous
Inter jet afin de tout faire pour éviter
que de tels drames ne se reproduisent
dans notre République madame la Première
ministre en cette semaine de congrès des
maires où de nombreux élus nous écoutent
comment pouvons-nous davantage
accompagner et rassurer nos communes
surtout en territoire rural pour que les
événements indispensables à la vie de
nos villages à l'image du bal de crépole
puissent perdurer dans la sérénité pour
vous répondre la parole est à madame la
Première
[Applaudissements]
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Bernard buit vous
l'avez rappelé monsieur le sénateur dans
la nuit de samedi à dimanche à Crépol
dans votre département de la Drome
Thomas un jeune de 16 ans a été tué à la
sortie d'une fête au cœur même de son
village avant toute chose je veux à mon
tour dire toute ma solidarité à sa
famille à ses proches à tous les
habitants de crépool je veux adresser
mes pensées aux personnes blessées
certaines sont encore dans un état grave
c'est un drame qui touche tout un
village nous sommes au côté de la mer de
Crépol madame Martine
lagu monsieur le sénateur ces violences
sont graves elles sont
inacceptables une enquête judiciaire a
immédiatement été ouverte 70 auditions
ont d'or et déjà été menées les
enquêteurs travaille d' rche-pied pour
faire toute la lumière sur ce drame
d'ors et déjà donc neuf personnes ont
ont été interpellé l'enquête permettra
de déterminer les responsabilités de
chacun j'ai confiance dans nos forces de
l'ordre et dans notre justice toute la
vérité sera faite sur ce crime les
auteurs et leurs complices devront
répondre de leurs actes aujourd'hui
l'heure est à l'enquête et au
recueillement comme vous je le sais
Monsieur le Sénateur je suis convaincu
que ce moment appelle à la retenue et à
la dcence utiliser ce drame pour jouer
sur les peurs c'est manquer de dignité
et de respect pour les
victimes monsieur le sénateur vous le
dites ce drame soulève des questions
plus larges mon gouvernement est bien
conscient des évolutions de la
délinquence en particulier dans nos
territoires ruraux c'est la raison pour
laquelle conformément aux engagement du
Président de la République et en
application de la loi d'orientation et
de programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur porté par le ministre Gérard
d'armanin nous créons 239 nouvelles
brigades de gendarmerie dont deux dans
votre département de la drog
239 nouvelles brigades ce sont plus de
2000 gendarmes supplémentaires dans nos
territoires ruraux monsieur le sénateur
je veux vraiment vous en assurer la
présence des forces de l'ordre partout
sur le territoire notamment dans la
ruralité c'est une priorité pour mon
gouvernement je vous remercie merci
madame la Première
ministre